[Musique]
ça c'est ton fils est maintenant le
portable par en dessous
dans l'eau vincent oui vraiment en
séries le camp mais j'ai plus rien quand
même
elle est morte de quoi d'actifs elle est
mort dans son sommeil et boom krak mais
enfin bon piston ce site ça va bien
c'est facile quand même ma vie mais
c'est quoi c'est une innovation une
crémation vous savez rien dit avant même
dans mon ami en question de fausto
papables chers amis n'ont pas passé mois
au pardon ce grand chantier on ne nous
écoute a pas ça suffit bonjour vous
appeler pour approche des cdd décédé
depuis trois heures qu'on cherche
partout maintenant 17 janvier vous
briguez il s'occupe une entreprise de
pompes funèbres
il attendait peut-être mais je rêve
c'est ma grand mère
une très belle verticalité ici on dirait
une bassine se passe avec la
tambourinette intérêts dans le même
temps je te rappelle qu'on ne pas de
quoi tomber elle se fait les obsèques de
sa grand-mère la tabelle mam c'est fait
un petit bar tu va les retrouver sa
petite femme là puisque t'es pas capable
de la larguer son petit caractère est un
coût mais mais sort sharif et nous fait
pas chier mais aux costumes les yeux
religion ça c'est le papa est un thermos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les papiers sont l'un tout va bien
simplement il nous manque le corps adieu
berthe 22 moiselle mon éternité
[Musique]